how business works this is worth knowing
these things so first of all square root
of the number of the people that you
employ will do half the work okay so if
you have 10 employees three of them do
half the work but if you have ten
thousand employees a hundred of them do
have to work that's a stable law across
all Enterprises that require creative
production it doesn't really matter
where you look you get the same pattern
so for example five classical composers
composed 95 percent of the clinic of the
classical repertoire then if you look at
their music of those five composers five
percent of their music is what's played
95 percent of the time that's true it's
like a tiny proportion of authors
dominate the best seller lists